think back to your childhood and ask
yourself what was the most pain you've
ever felt while growing up as we develop
our understanding of pain evolves
according to our different experiences
the older we get the injuries we
suffered as children like a scraped knee
or a bee sting rarely causes the same
level of distress as they used to of
course when you are young and unfamiliar
with sensations of pain what you really
need in that moment straight after
you've fallen off your bike or tripped
playing soccer is someone to pick you
back up and give your sore spot a kiss
perhaps you even need a bowl of warm
soup to comfort you luckily for you
scp-348
is exactly that while many of the
anomalies held in containment by the scp
foundation have earned the euclid or
infamous ketter class designations
scp-348 is one of the few considered to
be safe both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
eldritch abomination from another
dimension spreading its influence in our
world through memetic stimuli nor is it
a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the garden of eden to put it simply
scp-348
is a bowl a white ceramic bowl the kind
you would find almost anywhere in the
world it may even look indistinguishable
from the one in your kitchen cabinet of
course scp-348 is hardly as ordinary as
it outwardly appears to be and it
certainly isn't the only inanimate
object that the foundation keeps safely
stored away the key thing that
differentiates scp-348 from most other
anomalies is how genuinely harmless it
is its anomalous properties do not cause
injury to any individual that interacts
with it nor does this bowl have any
adverse effects on the world around it
scp-348 cannot bend or reshape reality
it does not cause the person eating from
it to have premonitions of their own
death and using it certainly does not
manifest a contract making entity at the
opposite side of the table so what makes
this bowl in any way anomalous what
about it categorizes it as an scp and
not just a harmless piece of fine
crockery well why don't we start with
how scp-348 was first discovered some
time ago the scp foundation was made
aware of rumors surrounding a child
living in an unknown part of the world
according to the intelligence gathered
by the foundation this child seemed to
possess some sort of healing ability or
at least this is what rumors suggested
upon further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as scp-348
this is not to say that the bowl has any
inherently supernatural healing
properties and it doesn't impart any
regenerative power to those that eat
from it either it does heal in a certain
sense but not in the way you're probably
imagining when the scp foundation
recovered scp-348
there were no markings on it indicating
where the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand-painted around both the inside and
outside of
scp-348 the ceramic surface also bore
the chinese letters shangshini which
translates to the phrase thinking of you
the child that first discovered it found
the ceramic bowl in the attic of their
home the child's parents were both
full-time workers and seemed to be
somewhat neglectful of their child
although they refused to comment on this
but according to the findings of the scp
foundation the child had come to rely on
scp-348
deciding to further investigate the
anomalous properties of scp-348
the foundation began testing it given
that the child who first discovered the
bull had relied upon it tests involved
foundation researchers presenting
certain children to scp-348 and
observing the results so was this bowl
haunted perhaps harboring some malicious
spirit or entity that sought to corrupt
these children maybe even healing them
in order to somehow use them as a vessel
to break into our world no and while may
have not healed in any overt or expected
way it did heal in at least a
metaphorical sense if presented with an
injured child sporting any form of minor
ailments such as a cut or a runny nose
scp-348 fills with warm soup and yes
that's right we said soup what kind you
may ask well that seems to vary
sometimes it is tomato soup other times
it might be chicken noodle soup while
the ingredients used in the soups are
often different there are notable
consistencies to our scp-348 heels if
anyone between the ages of 4 years old
and 18 years old sits down in front of
the blue flowered bowl then scp-348 will
fill with soup numerous young test
subjects brought in by the foundation to
eat from this particular bowl of soup
have reported that they enjoyed their
meal usually finishing the entire bowl
when permitted to by research staff many
of the injured children that were tested
have stated that the soup they eat from
scp-348 reminds them of their parents
cooking these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claimed that even
though they were in a room all alone
they didn't feel lonely when they were
eating the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that has just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on scp-348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bowl refills with more
soup one test of scp-348 saw a little
girl age eight and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a background screening made by
research personnel the girl lived with
her biological parents and apparently
had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when scp-348
filled with soup for her the girl took
almost half an hour to finish eating and
afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she ate by the
end of the meal this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal
in this instance no message appeared
within the bowl another child was
brought in to continue the testing of
scp-348
this time a boy of 10. unlike the
previous test this boy was not on good
terms with his parents and often argued
with them at the time of testing the boy
had sustained several minor bruises the
result of a small accident that occurred
while the boy had been out riding his
bike much like the little girl this
subject ate the suit that scp-348
presented him with this time though the
bull offered a message to the boy the
lettering found on the ceramic surface
of scp-348 simply read don't forget to
brush messages also appeared when an 11
year old boy with a slight cold ate soup
from the bowl this child had been
adopted by a foster family and after
eating from scp-348 he saw the message
i'm glad you're happy appear another
young test subject a boy aged six had a
similar experience in this instance the
child had several scrapes and scratches
from playing with his friends his
parents had divorced and he was living
with his mother at the time of testing
this time
scp-348's message to this boy read i'm
sorry son a seven-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before scp-348
she had lost her father to a traffic
accident some time before testing
commenced and received the message i
love you after finishing her soup
further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from scp-348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
scp-348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seem to be faded not the clear
hand-painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of scp-348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
was some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of this woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some career training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the scp-348 testing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became
estranged from her parents over the
years but unlike the previous test this
woman had taken it upon herself to not
only send money to her parents but also
arranged senior care for both as well
prior to testing her father had died
peacefully of natural causes after
spending his last days in the care that
this woman had paid for as the woman ate
the soup from the bowl she remarked
about its apparently bitter taste but
also described her meal as fulfilling
after she had finished the words thank
you appeared within scp-348
one other adult subject that produced a
noticeable result from scp-348 was a
40-year-old male the results of this
test appeared to be the most distinctly
different from any previous adult or
child by now researchers working for the
scp foundation had determined that
familial history seemed to play an
important role in the outcome of any
interaction with
scp-348 and this individual was
certainly different to most the man in
question had murdered his father roughly
a year before the testing took place he
began the test with scp-348 while
afflicted with aches in his back after
one taste of the soup that appeared in
the bowl before him the murderer was
immediately repulsed he complained about
the taste refusing to eat any more from
scp-348
shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but scp-348 immediately filled with
salt water which took three hours to
disappear from the bowl despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and elements the scp
foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in
scp-348 some are theorized because of
the family histories of some children
and adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of scp-348
to provide comfort to small children
dealing with pain both inside and out
after all isn't providing comfort what a
good bowl of soup anomalous or not is
best at now check out
scp-999 the tickle monster and a sea
snail's fantasy
scp-1867 a gentleman for more
fascinating anomalies that mean you no
harm